la ministre n'a pas reçu Monsieur
cifaoui très bien à ma connaissance
j'ai reçu
pour le compte de la ministre
le 22 avril
à 15h15
au Canadien de la ministre un
rendez-vous qui était organisé par par
le secrétaire de ministre pour qu'elle
reçoive la personne que vous avez cité
j'ai cité également la ministre n'a pas
pu pour des raisons de conflit d'agenda
et d'urgence assurés sur rendez-vous
mais de la représenter donc j'ai reçu et
c'est le seul rendez-vous que j'aurais
avec motif à oui sur ces questions là le
22 avril à 15h15
et je suis très clair et très précis sur
ce point mes collaborateurs au cabinet
de cipdr ont pu rencontrer Monsieur
cifaoui à plusieurs reprises
précédemment très certainement
fin mars fin mars Diabi également
il y a pu y avoir une il y a eu une
incitation une invitation à
envisager un projet associatif pour
recevoir un soutien
du cipdr et une fois que ce projet a eu
été communiqué et déposé je crois que
c'est le 9 avril c'est le cipdr dans ces
missions
administratives de gestion de demande de
subventions qui a géré l'entièreté de la
relation avec les porteurs de projet en
ce qui concerne en vrai on va y revenir
simplement
vous le savez le rapport de l'inspection
indique qu'il y a eu ces rencontres
entre mars et avril 2021 entre votre
cabinet de manière large il y en a une
avec vous mais c'est ainsi que c'est
indiqué dans le rapport de l'inspection
le rapport me se présente me semble-t-il
retranscrit les propos tenus par l'un
des protagonistes
en bas de page précise qu'elle n'est pas
en mesure de déterminer le nombre de
nature des rayons qui se sont tenus